welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul here with a major
announcement for all the subs out there
yes i have had a haircut we can we can
officially announce it dave down the
road done it but on top of that me and
the wife are also having twins yes twins
two boys gonna prestige them and
basically raise them as one person so
that they can be traveling magicians
throughout the entire land now they are
coming in less than three weeks very
excited but also very nervous as i'm
sure you can tell especially if you're a
parent two babies is a lot to take on
but we're full steam ahead at the
channel and i just want to kind of clear
up everything as i know some of you know
about this already but a lot of you
don't so i thought i'd go through what's
going to be happening in terms of videos
coming out content and basically just
the changes that are going on behind the
scenes now we have hired two new
full-time members of staff which i'm
very excited about they're they're
bloody lovely guys you'd love them
hopefully i'll introduce them one day
but they're both on holiday at the
moment so this is why i'm kind of
putting on this video but they're gonna
be handling things like editing um
helping me you know if if i get about
seven a.m and watch through a tv show
and i'm like did any of you guys notice
any easter eggs and like yeah boba fett
is the same character as the one from
return of the jedi so i can write stuff
down like that and just kind of helps me
with the day-to-day stuff i'm still
going to be running the breakdowns of
course going to be trying to do as many
as i can but some of them might not be
coming out all the time because i want
to spend time with the kids yeah i
haven't really had much time off for the
last three years if you've been
following the channel you know we've
pretty much posted about four videos a
week and i want to spend time with the
kids yeah so just let me off your
scumbag now saying all that we are going
to try and keep everything going as
usual but i'm i'm someone who's
basically a worst case scenario kind of
guy so i just thought i'd let you know
in advance so you know like where's all
these bloody breakdowns now speaking of
that i have been getting a lot of
comments asking where my peacemaker
breakdowns are and you know there's a
number of reasons for that now the first
thing is i tend to work from sunday up
to thursday and then i try and take
friday and saturday off just to sort out
personal things and sunday i'm usually
getting things ready for the editor to
start monday and then throughout the
week you know working towards beau
effect and stuff so unfortunately i
haven't had time in the schedule to
cover every single week but i will be
doing a full full series breakdown come
the end of it and i am really enjoying
it i've loved the first four episodes so
far and you know it's not me being some
marvel chill i love dc and i think
they've done an amazing job with the
show i just haven't had time to cover it
it's also not available in the uk at the
moment it's it's only out on hbo max in
the us which you know that streaming
service hasn't come over here so though
i could get
you know i could see the episodes
hypothetically if my uncle
had uh who lives in america had sent
them over but he hasn't so don't get the
lawyers involved the warner brothers and
but yeah i i just haven't really had the
time in my schedule and they're not
available over here so it's a bit of a a
weird legal issue as well around it but
really enjoying it um i appreciate all
the comments every video like you
scumbag why aren't you reviewing
peacemaker ryanair is much better but
yeah he's doing great breakdowns over
there i know mtf new rockstars is doing
them as well he's doing great ones as
well so there are people doing them it's
just i don't have the time at the moment
unfortunately now we are kind of trying
to work on that at the moment um but
with the babies coming in three weeks as
well i didn't want to necessarily like
start covering something every single
week and then
say my wife goes into labor on a
thursday and
i just can't cover it at all because i'm
down the hospital being like come on
bush um so yeah that's why i couldn't do
it bucket boba fett was another one that
was very close to not covering when it
was going to be eight episodes long and
then they cut it down to seven it was
actually the finale was meant to be on
the due date and then they could have
down so i was like well we've got this
one week if they don't come early um so
yeah that's basically what's happened
with it it's not because i i hate dc and
i don't think the show's good i just
haven't had time to cover it anyway
thanks for sitting through this very
very crap major announcement uh but yeah
i hope you enjoyed the news that i've
had a haircut and also thanks for thanks
for all the support you know we want to
keep the channel going as much as
possible i'm sure it will you know i'm
like i'll be posting videos all the time
still you know this is a full-time job
for me and there's plenty of parents out
there who've actually done proper work
whilst having kids whereas i'm just
gonna be sat in my room making videos so
i don't think it'll be as bad as i'm
making out my head but then i've had
other people tell me like well you'll
never get any sleep so we're gonna try
and work it out i might even end up
working through the night and just
getting audio ready for the editors but
hopefully you won't notice anything but
just in case you do i thought i'd put
this video out in advance to just let
you know what's happening in the future
and hopefully we hit the million
subscriber mark very soon that's still
the goal that's the most important thing
in my life right now that's all i care
about uh but yeah hopefully that's this
year and thanks again for all your
support it really means a lot hope you
enjoy the rest of your weekend and take
care yourself yeah peace
[Music]
is
[Music]